Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Two years ago, in 2016, we talked about a
paper that enabled us to sit in front of a
camera, and transfer our gestures onto a virtual
actor.
This work went by the name Face2face and showcased
a bunch of mesmerizing results containing
reenactments of famous political figureheads.
It was quite amazing.
But it is nothing compared to this one.
And the reason for this is that the original
Face2face paper only transferred expressions,
but this new work is capable of transferring
head and torso movements as well.
Not only that, but mouth interiors also appear
more realistic and more gaze directions are
also supported.
You see in the comparisons here that the original
method disregarded many of these features
and how much more convincing this new one
is.
This extended technique opens up the door
to several, really cool new applications.
For instance, consider this self-reenactment
application.
This means that you can re-enact yourself.
Now, what would that be useful for, you may
ask?
Well, of course, you can appear to be the
most professional person during a virtual
meeting, even when sitting at home in your
undergarment.
Or, you can quickly switch teams based on
who is winning the game.
Avatar digitization is also possible, this
basically means that we can create a stylized
version of our likeness to be used in a video
game.
Somewhat similar to the Memoji presented in
Apple's latest keynote with the iPhone X.
And the entire process takes place in real
time without using neural networks.
This is as good as it gets.
What a time to be alive!
Of course, like every other technique, this
one also has its own set of limitations.
For instance, illumination changes in the
environment are not always taken into account,
and long-haired subjects with extreme motion
may cause artifacts to appear.
In short, don't use this for rock concerts.
And with this, we are also one step closer
to full character re-enactment for movies,
video games and telepresence applications.
This is still a new piece of technology, and
may offer many more applications that we haven't
thought of yet.
After all, when the internet was invented,
who thought that it could be used to order
pizza or transfer Bitcoin?
Or order pizza and pay with bitcoin.
Anyway, if you have some more applications
in mind, let me know in the comments section.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!